you know you've had a lot of dope
moments over the last few months um i
know charlemagne is a big fan of yours
and and he doesn't co-sign a lot of new
artists man shout out charlemagne man
charlemagne shows crazy love like
organic natural facts he's one of the
most organic naturally just amazing
dudes i know man charlemagne shows so
much love that [ __ ] think that i'm
paying him the post now they think he's
doing a promo for labor so that's so
funny that's just insane you know but
he's like he's someone who like really
supports it gets behind it like where
did where do you where did he uh like
what do you know kind of the origin of
like how he discovered your [ __ ] oh vain
so hopefully shout out to joe vane
is a great guy man man
is the guy man yeah that's my guy he'd
be making some questionable fashion
decisions sometimes but well you know
listen hoban's a bigger guy so he you
know there's certain [ __ ] that probably
ain't made in his size it's the east
coast [ __ ] man it's just different out
there man shout out tree one [ __ ] had
on uggs with the uh knitted top wait
whole vane had it uggs
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait no
oh man no no oh i better say i will
roast that man right now but you you
feel me like oh baby
don't let me find out how they got uggs
bro cause i'll never let that probably
got a breath i put some i'll never let
that [ __ ] ever ever ever
hey
i'll bring this
into the charlemagne and uh charlemagne
[ __ ] with it heavy like jovane has
been a big part in just like a lot of
what's been happening vayne's great man
are you working with ovan yeah covain's
the best